sébastien on peut se demander quand même
si le gouvernement n'a pas pu aller plus
loin pourquoi ne pas imposer la
francisation complète par exemple le
gouvernement pense avoir adopté une
approche équilibrée qui respecte le
droit ou commettent si on veut où le
respect de certaines marques de commerce
et cet appel aux bons citoyens
corporatifs qui doit respecter
l'environnement dans lequel il fait du
commerce dans lequel il vit est ce qu'il
y avait cette menace nous ce danger que
les grandes compressions quittent le
québec au bout de québec si jamais la
réglementation était trop strict
on sait jamais trop si ces menaces là où
ces dangers là sont fondées il y avait
certainement la certitude au
gouvernement que si le retourner devant
les tribunaux il perdrait encore une
fois sa cause d'où cette approche de
règlement mais je vous rappelle un
règlement atteint son objectif si et
seulement si il est appliqué est-ce
qu'en cette période de rigueur
budgétaire ou d'austérité
l'office québécois de la langue
française a les moyens d'appliquer la
nouvelle réglementation ça on verra mais
la question se pose est aussi
traditionnellement les libéraux se
montrent prudents on est question
identitaire ce une question de valeurs
oui il a été critiqué sur son projet de
loi sur la neutralité religieuse de
l'état en disant qu'il n'allait pas
assez loin il a été critiqué aussi sur
cette défense de la langue française au
québec une certains disent qu'il manque
de volonté politique pour appliquer la
réglementation alors donc il a une
approche plus nuancée prenons ce moment
là que le parti québécois par exemple ça
s'explique peut-être par sa base
électorale beaucoup à montréal des
communautés anglophones et communautés
culturelles sont très sensibles à ces
questions linguistiques et là je veux
pas vous faire perdre aux illusions mais
dans les décisions politiques oui à
l'intérêt commun l'intérêt suprême
mais il ya aussi un ingrédient de
politique partisane c'était le cas avec
la charte des valeurs et c'est peut-être
le cas avec la décision du gouvernement
d'aujourd'hui
alors on verra comment cela sera reçue
merci beaucoup sébastien nous a pris
bonne foi